qu'est ce que je vais faire cet après
midi cette application permet de les
activités sportives et les touches
plutôt tenté par une visite aujourd'hui
par exemple à un petit château ça fait
longtemps
c'est parti une application 100 % et
loire pour trouver de quoi s'occuper
quand on les touristes et que l'on
souhaite organiser en six jours
rapidement et simplement éviter du
département tout tient dans la poche et
d'un simple clic on peut choisir un lieu
à visiter un restaurant un gîte et
regarder en ligne
c'est simplement l'usagé des visiteurs
qui une fois qu'ils sont arrivés sur
place peuvent être à la recherche sans
avoir réservé d'information de sites à
visiter d'hébergement ou de restaurant
est donc cette application va leur
permettre justement en fonction de là où
ils se trouvent
de voir ce qu'il ya autour d'eux dans
tous les services qui peuvent être
proposées au tourisme dans les locaux du
conseil départemental un service géré la
base de données plus de 600 structures
sont détesteriez est mis à jour qu'un
vie quotidiennement notre site c'est un
incident qui est assez fréquenté donc
après les prestataires safran en allant
sur notre site
du coup ils auront connu pendant très et
qu il y aurait il y aura beaucoup de
clients ou de prospects royer mais qui
vont venir sur notre site et qui vont
arriver sur leur site après à bhl le 6
to 28 est une application gratuite et
téléchargeable sur smartphones et
tablettes
[Musique]